l'espoir de retrouver des survivants des
appartements en sa faveur contre 6
autorise propres et sont encore en
détention l'humour qu'il rentre au pays
maintenant c'est votre
toutes été emportées par les boues
mais ce matin on s'interroge sur
l'emplacement du pedn cantine du grand
bornand une civette entassent fonds éco
école de kate bush m 2 me
à deux reprises en 1879 et en 1936 les
eaux du torrent a déjà tout emporté sur
son passage et malgré cela une
autorisation de terrain touristiques
avaient été délivrés il ya quinze ans
sans tenir aucun compte des et puis il y
a deux ans le précédent au savoy avait
réclamé une expertise sur le camping du
grand bornand une étude était en cours
et aurait pu aboutir en septembre
prochain au classement du site en zone
rouge c'est à dire à la fermeture du
camping par arrêté préfectoral